- By now, I think everyone has heard
of what happened in Uvalde, Texas.
I'm not gonna go into detail,
and new facts are coming
to light every single day.
But one thing it seems is
certain is that the police,
to put a charitably,
did not act in a way that most
people wanted them to act.
By all accounts,
there was a very long delay
between the time that the
police arrived on scene
and when they took action
to stop the shooter.
So, people angry at
the tragedy are asking,
"Can the police be held
legally responsible,
not for their action,
but for their inaction?"
And I'm not gonna hide
the ball on this one,
the answer is almost certainly no.
But the reason why might surprise you,
because most people believe
that the police have a legal duty to help.
And unfortunately, according
to the Supreme Court,
that is not the case.
While their motto may
be to protect and serve,
the police have absolutely
no duty whatsoever
to help anyone that's in trouble.
Now, normally, this would
be the part of the video
where I run through the factual summary
that gives rise to all
of the legal issues.
I'm not gonna do that today
because, honestly, it's just too hard.
But these are important legal issues.
And this is one of those videos
where it's not about
what the law should be,
it's about what the law is.
Now, we've talked a lot on this channel
about the difficulty in suing police
for the things that they do,
the mistakes they might have made.
Qualified immunity generally
protects police officers,
unless it was clearly established
that what they did was unconstitutional.
There are all kinds of
controversies in this doctrine.
This is not the video for
those particular questions.
But the question presented
by the Uvalde shooting is different.
Here, we're asking whether
government officials
can be sued for actions they did not take.
Now, the Supreme Court has ruled twice
that government actors like
police and social workers
actually have no duty to protect anyone.
This precedent was established in 1989
when the Supreme Court
decided the case of DeShaney
versus Winnebago County
Department of Social Services.
In that case, in 1982,
Joshua DeShaney was a four year old boy
living with his father,
Randy, in Wisconsin.
Randy had primary custody of the child
and had recently gone
through a second divorce.
Joshua's stepmother
told the Winnebago County
Department of Social Services
that Randy abused his son.
Randy denied it,
and the county took no
action to remove the child.
However, in 1983, Joshua was
seen at the ER for bruises.
The ER doctor notified social services,
and Joshua was removed from
Randy's custody for a few days.
Randy wasn't charged,
and the child was returned to his custody.
A social worker was
assigned to visit the home.
And in 1984, the social worker
visited the house 20 times,
noting that the child had bumps, bruises,
and injuries on his head.
The social worker also documented
that Randy failed to attend
his regular counseling sessions
or enrolled Joshua in preschool.
And during this time,
Joshua ended up in the ER
twice with suspicious injuries.
The social worker said that
she feared for his life
but took no action to
remove him from the home.
And unfortunately, in March of 1984,
one day after the social worker's visit,
Randy beat Joshua so hard
that he fell into a coma.
Joshua had severe brain damage
and was permanently paralyzed.
The state then placed Joshua
in an institution where he would remain
for the rest of his life.
Joshua DeShaney's mother
sued the Winnebago County
Department of Social Services,
alleging that the department
had deprived Joshua
of his liberty interest
in bodily integrity
in violation of his rights
under the substantive component
of the 14th Amendment's Due Process Clause
by failing to intervene to protect him
against his father's violence.
Now, the Due Process Clause
of the 14th Amendment
declares that no state shall
deprive any person of life,
liberty, or property
without due process of law.
DeShaney argued that the county
had a responsibility to protect Joshua
because it knew Randy abused him.
The social worker had tracked the abuse
on paper for over a year.
DeShaney argued that through
the social worker's visits,
the state had established
a special relationship
with Joshua that created a responsibility
to protect him from known dangers.
Then, chief justice of the
Supreme Court, William Rehnquist,
wrote the majority opinion,
which found that the Due Process Clause
only applies to states,
not to private citizens.
Since Randy was the one who beat his son,
the court reason
that the state didn't directly
cause Joshua's injuries.
And the majority also
rejected the argument
that the state made
Joshua more vulnerable.
The purpose of the Due
Process Clause, quote,
"was to protect people from the state,
not to ensure that the
state protected them
from each other."
The court held that the 14th Amendment
did not grant any citizen
a guarantee of, quote,
"minimal levels of safety and security."
The court also said
that people have no right
to governmental aid.
The court held that the Due Process Clause
would only apply if the
state had assumed custody
of a person against their will,
and then failed to
provide for their safety
and general wellbeing.
Justice Brennan and the
two other dissenters
saw it another way.
They believed that since
the state had acted
through the social work department,
they assumed the responsibility
for the child's safety.
The dissenters said that if
the state had never intervened,
then others in Joshua's
life, like his mother,
might have taken other actions
to get him away from Randy.
And basically, in the DeShaney case,
what happens is that a mother
is worried that her son,
who's in the custody of the father,
is being abused by the father.
She goes to the police, they
send social workers out,
social worker visits 20 times,
sees lots and lots of evidence of abuse.
Ultimately, the social
services doesn't do enough,
and the child is horribly
and permanently injured
by the father in large part
because social services allowed the child
to remain with the husband.
Now, there are obvious differences
between what happened in Uvalde
and a social worker who fails
to remove a child from a violent parent.
But that takes us to the 2005 case
of the town of Castle Rock,
Colorado versus Gonzales,
where the Supreme Court
applied the same rationale
to a case involving the police.
Now, in that case,
Jessica Gonzales had asked
for a restraining order
against her estranged husband.
There was a Colorado law
that made domestic violence
restraining orders mandatory
whenever one party felt threatened.
And the state trial court issued an order
prohibiting the husband
from seeing Ms. Gonzales
or their three daughters,
unless it was through
a pre-arranged visit.
Now, just one month later,
the husband kidnapped the three children.
Ms. Gonzales had direct
evidence that he had the kids
because he confirmed it on the phone.
She begged the police to search
for her husband right away
since she violated the court order.
Now, the Castle Rock Police Department
told Ms. Gonzales that
it could do nothing,
and told her she had
to wait until 10:00 pm
to see if her husband
brought the daughters home.
At 10:00 pm, the police told
Jessica to wait until midnight.
At midnight, she went
to the police station
to beg them to arrest her husband.
An officer took the report
and then went to dinner.
A few hours later,
Gonzales's husband went
to the police station
and opened fire.
Police killed him in the melee.
And when they searched his truck,
they found the three
girls dead in the back.
Gonzales's husband had
murdered all three that night.
Ms. Gonzales sued the Castle
Rock Police Department
for violating her due process rights.
And the Tenth Circuit Court of Appeals
found that she had a, quote,
"protected property interest
in the enforcement of the terms
of her restraining order,"
which the police had violated.
But the Supreme Court
reversed that decision,
ruling that Gonzales
had no constitutionally
protected property interest
in the enforcement of
the restraining order,
and, therefore, could not claim
that the police had violated
her right to due process.
Justice Antonin Scalia
wrote the majority opinion.
He reasoned that the state
law didn't entitle anyone
to mandatory action by police,
even though the issue
into the restraining order
was mandatory under Colorado law.
Restraining orders provide the grounds
for arresting a person
constrained to the order,
but that doesn't mean that the recipient
can force the police to act.
Scalia wrote that under the Colorado law,
police have discretion to decide
whether to enforce an order,
and if so, how they would do so.
The court concluded that, quote,
"since Colorado had not created
such an entitlement to mandatory action,
Gonzales had no property interest,
and the Due Process Clause
was therefore inapplicable."
The court ultimately concluded
that unless a legislature
specifically said,
"We're creating this
right, and if we breach it,
the private citizen can
then sue the government,"
then the citizen is out of luck.
And as one court put it, quote,
"Law enforcement officers
often consider themselves
responsible for protecting the public
and deterring criminal activity.
However, the legal doctrine that specifies
the legal duty of law enforcement officers
holds that they have a duty to the public,
but not to individual citizens."
This is what's known as
the public duty doctrine.
Doctrine means that the officers
don't have a duty to protect citizens
from harm by a third party.
In other words, there is no clear duty
to protect individual citizens.
Now, that being said,
the DeShaney decision recognized
two possible exceptions
to the general rule that
the state has no duty
to protect people from harm.
The first is what's called
the special relationship exception,
which holds that the constitution imposes
upon the state a duty of care
towards individuals
who are in its custody.
As it's usually summarized, quote,
"When the state takes a
person into its custody
and holds him there against his will,
the constitution imposes upon it
a corresponding duty to
assume some responsibility
for his safety and well-being."
So when the state has a special
relationship with someone,
there may be a duty to protect.
If this relationship exists,
the state official must
take reasonable steps
to ensure the safety
and care of that person
and to safeguard them
against foreseeable risks.
However, most courts
say that the only time
the state forms a special relationship
is through incarceration,
institutionalization,
or other similar restraint
of personal liberty.
And most courts reject the theory
that people waiting to be rescued
are in police custody and control.
This is particularly true
in the Fifth Circuit,
and perhaps the most
analogous Fifth Circuit case
is Salas versus Carpenter,
where a county clerk was taken hostage
at the courthouse by
her abusive boyfriend.
And during the hostage negotiation,
the sheriff ordered that the city SWAT
and Hostage Negotiation
Teams leave the courthouse.
He then replaced them
with county personnel,
not trained for SWAT or
hostage negotiations.
The man killed the county clerk,
and the Fifth Circuit
sided with the sheriff,
finding that he did not violate
her constitutional rights
by using untrained negotiators.
The court said, quote,
"Generally, the absence
of a special relationship
defeats any due process
claim based on a failure
to provide protective services.
The victim was not held in state custody
or otherwise prevented by the
state from caring for herself.
This was a failed rescue effort."
And it's easy to see
how the Fifth Circuit,
which covers Texas, would
probably make the same call
in the hypothetical Uvalde case.
The police were doing something,
they were securing the parking lot,
and stopping parents from getting inside
where they might get hurt.
And just because the effort
failed and failed badly,
probably wouldn't change the
Fifth Circuit's analysis.
But under the DeShaney case,
there is a second exception,
and that is called the
state-created danger exception.
And under that theory,
some courts have recognized
that state officials have a
duty to protect individuals
from harm when their actions created
or exacerbated a danger
to that individual.
But here, it seems like this
exception wouldn't apply.
The police didn't help,
at least not in the way
that most people wanted them to help,
but, at the same time,
they also did not create
the situation itself.
Now, those of you that
have been paying attention,
might have come up with a legal theory
that might differentiate what
happened to Uvalde, Texas
from the prior precedent.
And that is that children
are mandated to go to school.
Often, those schools are
provided by the government.
And in this case, this massacre
occurred at a public school.
So aren't the children within
the custody of the government,
and doesn't the government
then have an obligation
to provide for the health
and safety of the children,
especially a school that
has a police officer,
and a school district that
has its own police department?
Well, it's complicated,
but it probably doesn't turn out the way
that you might want,
because, unfortunately,
this is not the first time
there has been a massacre
on school campus.
And a relatively recent case
is almost directly on subject.
And that is the case arising
out of the Parkland situation.
In late 2020, the Eleventh
Circuit Court of Appeals
sided the Castle Rock and DeShaney cases,
and dismissed a lawsuit brought
by the victims of the
Parkland, Florida shooting
at the Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School.
Now, there, the students
alleged that the county sheriff
and deputies incompetently responded
to an active shooter situation
violating their due process rights.
The deputies knew that the shooter
was a danger to the community,
and school officials had also known
that the shooter was deeply
troubled and had made threats.
The plaintiffs alleged that
the deputies had failed
to intervene during the shooting.
And they also noted that
one deputy prevented EMS
from providing lifesaving care
and blocking them from entering the school
during the shooting.
The Eleventh Circuit Court of Appeals,
which is one step below the
Supreme Court, found that,
"A plaintiff can only allege a
substantive due process claim
in two situations.
First, when the person was
in the government's custody
and second, when government
official's conduct is arbitrary
or shocks the conscience."
Now, first,
the court held that the children
were not in police custody,
and as far as shocking the conscience,
the court held that in an
active shooter situation,
police have to make split-second decisions
in the midst of chaos.
In this situation, quote,
"An official's conduct
will shock the conscience
only when it stems from a,
quote, 'purpose to cause harm.'"
That means that a plaintiff
can only sue if they can show
that the government officer
purposefully caused harm.
If the police officer didn't
intend to hurt anyone,
then they can't be sued.
And with respect
to whether the children
were in government custody,
the court held, quote,
"It is well-established
that school children
are not in a custodial
relationship with the state.
A custodial relationship exists only
if the government places limitations
upon individual's ability to act
on his own behalf that are similar in kind
to incarceration or other forms
of involuntary confinement."
School attendance, even
when compelled by truancy
and compulsory attendance laws,
is not similar in kind to incarceration
or institutional confinement.
"Ordinarily, there are no
custodial relationships
in the public school system,
even if officials are
aware of potential dangers
or have expressed an intent to provide aid
on school grounds."
And in the Parkland case,
the biggest controversy
was about Scot Peterson,
a Broward County Sheriff's Deputy
and school resource officer.
Peterson stayed outside
of a school building
for over 40 minutes
as students and faculty
members were gunned down.
And the state of Florida charged Peterson
with neglect under a statute
that applies to caregivers.
Now, this is generally a novel
interpretation of the law
which usually applies to parents
or adult household members or teachers.
Now, Peterson will stand
trial on this criminal case,
but the Eleventh Circuit
dismissed the civil case
against Peterson for the same reasons
it dismissed the cases
against other defendants,
that the students were not
in a custodial relationship
with the officials,
even the school's armed resource officer.
A lot of people disagree
with this particular ruling,
and it can be solved with legislation,
but as it currently stands,
there is no inherent cause of action
based on the constitution
that would allow parents
and teachers and victims to sue the police
for inaction at Uvalde.
And unfortunately, that is
the current state of the law.
Now, if you'd like to
actually do some good,
one thing I can recommend
is a company I work with
called Tab for a Cause
which lets you raise money for
the charity of your choice,
just by opening tabs while
you're browsing the internet.
Tab for a Cause is a
Google Chrome extension
that allows you to pick
a charity of your choice.
Then every time you open up a new tab,
instead of a blank page,
it displays a new customizable tab
that displays a couple of tiny ads.
And the money that you
generate through those ads
is then donated to the
charity of your choice,
and you can see how much
you're generating in real time.
I've worked with Tab
for a Cause for years,
and LegalEagle viewers
have actually raised
over $35,000 for charity
just by themselves.
And it's great because
Tab for a Cause's finances
are 100% transparent.
So you can see for yourself
how much you've raised
and where it's gone.
So if you're in the mood
to do something good for this world,
all you have to do is click on the link
that's on screen right
now or in the description,
and install the browser
extension, that's it.
And then every page that you open,
will create revenue that goes to charity.
It's a little thing,
but, by a lot of us working together,
we can make a tiny
difference in this world.